il ya 30 ans disparaissait rené goscinny
génial inventeur d'astérix de lucky luke
et du petit nicolas
il fut aussi auteur de chroniques que sa
fille anne a regroupé dans un album
exceptionnel
marie-hélène bono et des sièges trois
scénarios rené goscinny fait toujours
rigoler rené goscinny paris 16e rené
goscinny le scénariste de paris que la
seine-et-oise nous envient scénariste
mais aussi chroniqueur goscinny pour
preuve ces textes parus entre 64 et 76
des chroniques parfois déjà illustré
comme celle ci avec gotlib paru dans
pilote vous signez poser la question
comment nos ancêtres savait-il ce qu'ils
étaient comestibles gottlieb a bien
connu goscinny en travaillant à pilote
en 1965
ensemble ils ont commis les
dingodossiers ne garde que des bons
souvenirs parce que c'est idiot de dire
ça mais c'est le premier grand bonhomme
de la bd qui m'a fait confiance
les textes de goscinny avec des inédits
de dessinateurs d'aujourd'hui l'auteur
évoque la gourmandise ou encore le
métier obscur de scénariste c est là qu
est une facette plus étiqueté écrivain
les gens la connaissent moins et moi il
me tient à coeur
enfin bien que méchant vous aimez ou
distraire et vous allez au cinéma il
faut faire la queue pour entrer se
réjouir quand la queue s'allonge
derrière soir pour françois boucq qui a
illustré ce texte l'esprit goscinny est
passé chez de nombreux auteurs de bd
cette complicité bien sûr est passé par
les dessinateurs et qui ont été je
dirais la génération avant la mienne et
bien sûr aussi qui s'est diffusé dans ma
génération comme pour florence cestac
qui croque les repas d'affaires pour l
goscinny reste un modèle il a créé des
choses qui sont indémodables mai
qui sont toujours d'actualité c'est
rentrer dans nos patrimoines de france
est 30 ans que goscinny nous a quittés
trente ans que son regard espiègle sur
le monde continue de nous amuser